so yeah we have done uh this autometer
we have done in in Python and now we
have this ambitious project to do
regular expressions in Python which is
quite a useful little exercise because
running regular expression is actually
like grab the the unit command which we
have mentioned uh is is sort of a useful
application we have done deterministic
finite autometer DFAS and nfas and we
have looked at translations in both
directions and we've done this in Python
beautiful enough and then last session
we looked at regular expressions and we
have just done them on paper and now
today we're going to do them in Python
okay let's not look at the definition of
regular expression which is here so
let's not look at it yeah but let's look
at an example here's an example regular
expression which is sort of our running
example so what's the idea so it starts
starts with B plus Epsilon as b or
nothing and then there is a sequence of
a BS and then there is an A or nothing
and basically what this is It's a
sequence of A's and B's always
interchanging yeah I mean you can have
just an a you can have also nothing it's
also okay so these are the words this is
the language of this regular
expression so now the first question is
how do we represent a regular expression
what is a regular expression so what's
an expression actually so we've done a
video about this arithmetic expressions
and there are trees if I turn this this
uh regular expression into a tree that's
what I get yeah I wrote a pent for the
sort of invisible just one after the
other which is make explicit here I call
it a pent then there is this plus star
operation and down there epsilons and
and symbols and so this Tre is a
representation of a regular expression
now we have have to to have to to turn
this tree into into a python object so
I'm going to Define python classes and
since this is a bit much I'm I'm I'm
have done prepared this like you know if
you if you have these chefs cooking
something they prepare some sources so I
have lots of prepared sources today
because the recipe today is is a little
bit um involved let's say okay so here I
have the find a class of regular
expression which is an abstract class so
I'm not giving a way to create aular
expression but I have subclasses and
each of these subclasses correspond to
one way of making regular expression I
empty is the empty regular expression
Epsilon we've seen is the the one which
is just the empty word symbol is was one
symbol plus we have also seen a pend and
star these are the ways to make regular
expressions and I also have some boiler
plate every regular expression can print
itself okay and now here I have I have
typed in this tree as a python code let
me just run this and now I have E1 for
E1 is a regular expression and like it
can actually print itself as we can see
Okay cool so we have a representation of
regular Expressions but what can we do
with it we want to run it I want to have
a run function yeah here I want for
every regular expression I want to have
a run function right so I want to have
run and it gets a a word and it returns
true or false it returns a a bullion
yeah so if this word is is an element of
the regular expression I mean of the
language say yes otherwise said no now
there's a little extra thing we have to
supply we have to supply the alphabet
because that that's an extra parameter
so we we want to implement this run
function now what's the idea so if you
look at this picture
again then I indicated that actually
regular expressions and NFA have a close
relationship in particular there is a
translation from regular Expressions to
NFA to nondeterministic finite autometer
and we have already defined the Run
function for nfas so let's have a quick
look at nfas again we want to implement
the run function for regular expression
piggy Begging On The Run function for
nfas which we have already
defined okay let's have a look at the
nfas so that's we have done previously
this is very simple an NFA has a set of
State an alphabet a transition function
set of initial States set of final
States and uh we have a run
function which get a word sort of keeps
track of the states in which the NFA
could be and and at the end it checks
whether the set of states and the final
states have a non-empty intersection
this end here is actually the
intersection operator from set theory
okay we have two example finite
autometer so that's n zero this was the
autometer and recognizes that the the
symbol before the last symbol is
one okay this is n0o I've defined it
here so that's basically hacking in this
diagram as as a definition of a
expression so I can I can do this n z.
run and then one Z let's say and
hopefully it says yes it says yes okay
that's already enough and and I have
another finite automaton which I call N1
and N1 recognizes whether the last
symbol is a one so it has here 0 one it
stays in zero but as as soon as the last
symbol is a one it goes in in here and
that's this uh I I hack this in as N1
okay this is a two examples of fin
autometer which we're going to use in a
minute so now back to our regular
Expressions so we want to Define this
run function what we're going to
implement is this translation I'm going
to implement a method NFA which gets the
alphabet and returns an NFA so it
returns a Nona Mystic find autom which
corresponds to this regular expression
that's the idea and and and and once we
have this we can Implement uh the Run
function which gets the alphabet and the
word and it returns okay return not Red
Run Red Run is not right okay it returns
it converts itself to an NFA and then
runs this on the word okay so still Red
Run and now I can it boils down to
implement this NFA function so in the
spirit of test driv
development I'm going to write some unit
tests so um first of all write a test
function which g a regular expression
and the word and now we fix the sigma it
prints the expression it prints the word
and then it runs the expression on the
word and tells you true or false and we
do some tests for this this AB example
maybe you should also have a negative
test
okay
uh
so yeah so for example the empty ver
should be in at a a should be in it AB B
should be not in it AB a yes b a b a b
is also fine whereas bab aab should be
not fine okay so that's that's our test
Suite right so how are we going to
implement uh so I'm I'm I'm I'm not
going to go all the details let's just
look at at at some examples okay so
let's look at at three examples the
empty regular this is too
small the empty regular expression the
Epsilon and the
symbol now I have implemented the NFA
method which constructs the
corresponding NFA but to do this I need
to implement some factories which
produces produce the nistic finet
autometer the nfas is co responding to
it okay let's look at these factories I
need a factory for the empty NFA so
maybe I can draw this what
is what is the NFA recognizes the empty
language it is yeah definitely an empty
language yeah it's the empty NFA but the
empty NFA recognizes the empty language
yeah okay and and so here when I do this
in in Python I say out the empty set of
states is the empty uh transition
function the empty set of initial States
the empty set of final stat that's
that's the the empty NFA very very easy
so now Epsilon what's the Epsilon okay
let me let me draw some pictures so here
this is the NFA for the empty language
intentionally left empty now we have
this Epsilon so this is a little bit
more
complicated it has got one state which
is initial and
final so we start here if nothing comes
we say yes if something comes we we lose
it okay so here also exactly this
implementation in Python we say okay
there is uh one state and then no
transitions the initial State and the
final state is just this okay and now
the symbol now we have one symbol and we
want to Define an NFA which recognizes
exactly this symbol so so how do we do
this oh it's it's we have actually two
states initial state
and the final State and we have one
transition and that is the regular
expression a so here I do this we have
two states we have Sigma as we as as as
we get it and we have one transition
from zero to sim we have just one
consequence one next state which is the
state one this zero is the only initial
State one is the final
State translation
so let's
uh let's look at this from the point of
view of regular expression so now I'm
calling these factories now I have to to
do to say this is a class method so I
have to say NFA mty nf. Epsilon and
whatever NFA do symbol okay so we have
this un test yeah the empty doesn't even
recognize the empty word the Epsilon one
recognizes the empty word uh but not the
word a uh the a symbol doesn't say false
for the empty string but is true for a
it's just as
expected okay so now we get to the more
interesting one so let me do this Plus
in in some detail yeah we have to Define
uh uh Factory which get two automaton
builds a new one which recognizes the
union of the language yeah so it's it's
like know we have to to implement this
plus and it turns out uh on on paper
it's very simple so how do we Define how
do we construct the plus of two regular
of two automaton or the automaton which
recognizes a word from either language
let's see I have here n zero one
automatic here and one another automaton
and all I
do is put it together so here these two
I'm just putting them together I have
one bigger
automaton and this autom will recognize
the word either from this language or
from this language okay yeah okay so
let's do the factory for plus here is a
little bit of subtlety because if you
look at this automatan so so we want to
Define this plus plus the factory plus
given gets two automat call them a z and
A1 or call them A1 A2 and now I need to
construct the states of the union
aor and the question is how do I do this
so I have n Zer has got some states
012 and N1 has some states so how can we
put two sets together now what's the
wrong answer Union that's the wrong
answer that's the wrong answer so why is
it the wrong answer because n0
doq Union which is a bar N1
Q is 012 is a union but if you look at
this picture here we have five states
not three and if we if you combine this
automatan and and and overlap these
states maybe in this example it works in
general it will not work because we get
into some chaos yeah so there is some
some unintended interaction between
these automat so I need What's called
the disjoint Union let me let me just
run this and I have implemented it
myself but it's not very difficult so I
have implemented the method D Union so I
can now take the disjoint Union of two
set let's just n the Q And1
doq and what it is
doing it it it labels the one from the
first set with with a false and it
labels the element of the second set
with a true and then put them together
and this makes sure that they're kept
separate yeah so this Union this this
joint Union operator is what I then use
so I I I have prepared this already okay
so here okay for for the alphabets I
take the normal Union but for the states
I take the disjoint Union and then I
have implemented a little method which
can also uh lift the function the Delta
to the disjoint Union yeah and then
initial State final states are the dist
Union and I get a new
automaton
and so I can I can now I I can for for
example I can do NFA plus of two
automaton okay n z and
N1 and I get a complicated new automaton
which if you look in detail is really a
representation of this very simple
action putting two pictures together but
we have to be take here that everything
is kept separate so I can now implement
the the NFA method for plus using the
plus Factory and here there is oh scary
thing going on there's some recursion
going on because to translate a plus
regular expression I now have to
recursively translate the sub trees and
then
plus them together I test plus Epsilon a
so let's see whether this
works so the unit test for plus so if
you have a plus Epsilon we recognize
both the A and the empty word but we
still don't recognize a seems to work
okay so let's uh tell the rest of the
story we have two more uh Constructors
two more uh yeah two more uh sub classes
here a pen end and star and for each of
them we have to find a factory now I'm
going to give you the code let's just
show how it works so I have to implement
a factory for a pent and a factory for a
star now let me do this at least on
paper how do I do a factory for for a
pent so I have one automaton for the
first bit let's call it nn1 and one
automaton for the second bit and two and
I want to run one after the other so I
first of all I put them together
like for plus I just put big thing
around them I put them together but I I
only at the initial State for the first
and the final State for the second and
then here if here is a final state of
the first automater and here is an
initial state of the second I'm adding a
what's called an Epsilon transition I
can silently go from the end of the
first to the beginning of the second so
this is N1
and two just one after the other and if
you look at this implementation here
there are a few things to to comment on
but what I'm basically doing is I put
these two together then I add the
injection of the first set as initial
State and the injection of the final
state of the second as the final State
and then I say for any final state in
the first and for any uh initial state
of the second add an Epsilon transition
and here have a little method what it
means to add Epsilon transitions to an
NFA and star is actually not not very
different so you have an
NFA you just take it so this n and now
we have n star and and and and what we
do is we first of all add the empty
language so that we not language that's
the empty word and then we have to
shortcut here from Epsilon transition
from the from the final stat
to the initial States so we add all
these lots of
extra transitions
like we can go around as many times as
we like M and that's this few lines of
code here uh and also adding an an Epson
transition and now going back to the
regular
Expressions okay let me go to my last
prepared source so now I have this
Factory for plus the factory for and I'm
using here for pent also recursively
translating the expression and for Star
I recursively translate the expression
and then use my star
Factory and okay I I have the wrong test
so that's very bad how that this
happen Okay uh let's go to
here let's copy the unit test over which
I wanted to
do let's hope it works
okay let's
see so here okay oh oh this it didn't
work no that's that's a nice thing so
here I I I I checked the unit
test and the unit test doesn't work it
says false for b a b a b and then I
realize it's maybe not my code it's I
have the wrong test EX
sample which I had before let me just
copy it from
here yeah because it that that's also
the wrong one oh okay that's the wrong
one everywhere okay so it should it it
should it's B plus
Epsilon yeah and it finishes with a
otherwise it's
wrong and now I have to change this with
B
and that's with a this is a
problem if you do test based
developments your test should be right
that's an interesting B test
failed okay this time it it seems to
work so we have this complicated
expression and we what what do we say we
say the empty word is true the a is true
AB is true ABB is false AA is true b a b
a b is true and b a b a a b is false so
so seems to work so now for
entertainment yeah I asked what's the
language of this regular expression and
now we can resolve the mystery a little
bit at least we can play around with it
so I have here implemented this
expression as a tree as a python
expression and now I can run it so it
says it says yes for one one it says
false for
one0 it says also false for 1 1 but it
says yes for 1 1 0 and it says yes for 1
001 okay starts and ends at
one oh no okay uh everything which end
with one you think okay let's see
whether this that certainly uh seems to
be justified uh by so far uh but if you
just had one then it should recognize
one right yeah
it doesn't okay go then that's that's me
go we need more info yeah we leave it I
mean I I'm going to okay I'm I'm going
to uh publish this code and then
everybody can play around and figure out
what is the language I mean there's some
binary numbers here right maybe has
something to do with binary numbers
there's some some property of binary
numbers which correspond to this regular
expression
okay
there's a few important properties of
hash functions that we care about
fortography but the most important one
perhaps is that it's essentially pseudo
random so that means that we put in ABC
the literal adding and incrementing and
decrementing these counts can become
surprisingly um punishing in terms of
performance